Now, let's just take a look at each of the steps one-by-one.
This first step "E" can be rewritten by (E) corresponds to rule two.
Must have used rule two to do that. Then here, I just changed the "E" to a "T" that's rule one.
But then down here, I somehow changed this "T" to an "E + E".
We only have two rules to play with, and only one of them starts with a "T".
So, I must have used rule four to do this, and this tells me exactly what it has to be.
"T" goes "E + E", so it must've been "E + E", and down here,
the only thing I've changed is "E" goes to "int".
That's not currently one of my grammar rules. It must have been rule three, "E" goes to "int".
Remember, every step in the parse tree
corresponds to taking some part of the current input and using one of the rewrite rules.